grande soirée électorale se poursuit en
bourgogne franche comté dispositif
exceptionnel mis en place pour ce
premier tour des élections législatives
résultats analyses réactions au plus
près de chez vous comme au niveau
national on retrouvera nos journalistes
en direct des différents départements de
la région avec les enjeux et bien sûr
les premiers résultats dès que nous les
aurons des résultats dans les 27
circonscriptions analysé sur ce plateau
par catherine aime syrie et lilian melet
et bien sûr aussi des invités je voulais
présenterait dans un instant les
réactions elles sont aussi en direct sur
le web et les réseaux sociaux on suit ça
de près tout au long de la soirée avec
elsa bezin et bien sûr les résultats les
réactions c'est en temps réel sur notre
site internet
bfc point france 3 point fr et sur les
réseaux sociaux en suivant france 3
bourgogne et france 3 franche comté
alors je vous présente rapidement les
invités qui nous ont rejoint didier
parisse pour la république en marche
michel neugnot pour le parti socialiste
maxime thiébaut pour le front national
et catherine vandriesse pour les
républicains
avant de leur donner la parole et de
commencer à débattre sur les projections
nationales et les premières estimations
des instituts de sondage
je vous propose de nous rendre tout de
suite à chalon sur saône où nous attend
christophe sirugue ministre du
gouvernement de bernard cazeneuve donc
ministre de françois hollande sortant
qui est ce soir qui annonce ce soir
qu'il ait battu christophe sirugue
bonsoir vous payez ce soir votre
engagement auprès sera soit élan
hollande pendant ce quinquennat
je crois que comme d'autres candidats
d'abord je constate le taux d'abstention
particulièrement fort qui est le premier
enseignement qu'il faut tirer le
deuxième élément c'est bien évidemment
que les électrices et les électeurs ont
choisi de donner directement une
majorité au président de la république
est par ailleurs en effet c'est vrai que
l'étiquette du parti socialiste mais
j'assume de l'avoir porté avec fierté et
une étiquette qui aujourd'hui porte bien
sûr
le risque de ce résultat que
j'enregistre aujourd'hui est que
j'admets bien évidemment christophe
sirugue c'est l'étiquette du parti
socialiste où c'est le bilan ou et c'est
le bilan du quinquennat ce soir que vous
payez je ne crois pas que l'on puisse
répondre aussi directement que cela à
votre question encore une fois je crois
que quand on regarde les résultats
pour ce qui concerne la 5e
circonscription de saône et loire c'est
d'abord pour ceux qui se sont déplacés
aux urnes
et malheureusement ils ne sont pas assez
nombreux mais pour ceux qui se sont
déplacés aux urnes c'est d'abord la
volonté de donner une majorité au
président de la république et je crois
que c'est cet élément là qu'il faut
prendre en compte par ailleurs bien sûr
il est vrai que le score de la france
insoumise qui est relativement important
c'est qu'il n'y aura pas de candidat de
gauche à cette élection du 18 juin
prochain c'est bien sûr un élément de
préoccupation pour des gens qui comme
moi sont des gens de gauche je le
revendique comme telle qui porte des
valeurs et qui ce soir font cet amer
constat on n'a pas parlé de chiffres est
ce que vous avez des chiffres à nous
donner sur cette 5ème circonscription de
saône et loire vous nous avez dit vous
même que vous étiez éliminer ce que vous
avez des chiffres
écoutez là on y sont les chiffres dont
je dispose son tronc pas certain
néanmoins la tendance est forte vous
savez comme moi que pour être au
deuxième tour il faut faire douze
ennemis % des inscrits ce qui est loin
du score que je réalise donc à
l'évidence ce seront les deux premiers
qui seront en possibilité de concourir
au deuxième tour et je ne serai pas
parmi ces deux premiers christophe
sirugue un mot sur le deuxième tour
est-ce que vous avez d'ores et déjà un
appel
un souhait pour ce deuxième tour écoutez
je vais réunir bien sûr toutes celles et
tous ceux qui m'ont accompagné dans
cette campagne électorale pour savoir ce
que nous allons faire dans le cadre du
deuxième tour et nous serons très clair
et nous nous exprimerons le plus
rapidement possible pour dire ce que
nous ferons à titre personnel parce que
je pense que nous sommes dans une
période où nous n'avons pas à dire à nos
électrices one aux électeurs ce qu'ils
ont à faire
par contre nous pouvons à titre
personnel dire ce que nous ferons merci
à christophe sirugue pour cette première
réaction je rappelle donc les qualifiés
c'est gilles platret
et christophe gauvin qui est raphaël
gourdin pardon qui seront donc au second
tour dans cette cinquième
circonscription de saône et loire on va
donner la parole à nos invités sur ce
plateau pour commenter les premières
projections les premières estimations
nationales on parle de près de 400
aujourd'hui 400 députés la république en
marche autour de 400 députés la
république en marche qui pourraient
faire leur entrée au palais bourbon
alors évidemment didier parisse
ce soir c'est plutôt la fourchette autre
que vous atteignez ouais vous eu raison
d'eux je regrette comme vient de le
faire
christophe sirugue le taux d'abstention
parce que malgré tout on pouvait espérer
et dans la campagne que les uns les
autres nous avons menées nous avons cru
sentir une vraie envie politique de nos
concitoyens dont on pouvait espérer un
meilleur un meilleur résultat au plan de
l'abstention c'est ainsi ce que je
retiens en tout cas c'est que c'est que
clairement les français ont du bon sens
ils ont souhaité confirmer le choix qui
avait été fait à l'élection
présidentielle et par ailleurs ils ont
montré clairement leurs envies de de
renouvellement leurs envies de
recomposition leurs envies de de
remettre la france en mouvement et ça ne
peut être pour les candidats dans hqe
une satisfaction
un mot tout de même on vient d'entendre
christophe sirugue c'était quelqu'un qui
était pas forcément très éloignés des
positions des manuels macron qu'à
lui-même était dans le même gouvernement
précédent est ce que vous n'avez pas du
regret finalement vous en marche de
peut-être faire partir ce type d'élu oui
sans doute christophe sirugue état est
un élu de valeur il l'a montré récemment
dans son parcours ministériel
néanmoins les français ont besoin une
chose claire
le président de la république a montré
une une louve
ic une besoin d'une majorité large sur
un programme qui lui-même comporte 120
mesure environ qui a été le résultat de
d'un long travail de préparation 30
mille français ont été vus 500 experts
je dire à un moment il a fallu que les
uns et les autres se positionne et
finalement le pro 22,2 des manuels
macron autour duquel légende en marche
se sont retrouvés c'est un programme qui
est devenu l' axe central
et puis autour insérons de personnes
pouvaient ou pas tourné ou six
agglomérations regrette à titre
personnel la situation politique du
parti socialiste aujourd'hui et dont tu
as récemment on a socialiste qui est
présent sur ce plateau michel neugnot
ce soir le parti socialiste est mort on
n'est jamais mort en politique parce que
l'on soit malade alors voilà ce que l'on
peut dire c'est une confirmation comme
ça a été dit de la volonté des français
de donne une large majorité aux
pressions de la république pour ce qui
concerne le parti socialiste nous étions
pas requis de nous sommes partis d'un
score aux présidentielles de 6 36% en
train de dire que quand on part de si
bas on peut améliorer les choses ça non
non non non on peut c'est parce que je
dis attendez j'ai pas de donner des
signes de victoire ce soir force qu'il
faut être réaliste sur les choses qui
allaient les choses étaient très plombé
par le résultat de notre candidat à la
présidentielle on essayait de remonter
la faire avec des candidats
dans les circonscriptions qui ont fait
un travail mais a priori ce sera pire
qu'en 1993 le résultat on va faire un
tour avec elle a besoin sur les réseaux
sociaux pour voir les premières
réactions
oui peut-être un résultat un tweet de
christophe cariste journaliste à france
3 je vais y arriver
qui nous dit qu dans la circonscription
la quatrième de côte-d'or celle du
député sortant françois sauvadet on se
dirige à priori vers un duel yolaine de
courson face à charles barrière
d'enghien duel la république en marche
udi donc dans la circonscription la
quatrième de côte-d'or merci m
puisqu'on est dans les résultats les
premiers tout premiers résultats qui
nous parviennent on va rejoindre à
auxerre à la préfecture de l'yonne
sébastien kérou sébastien vous avez déjà
les premiers éléments à nous donner
oui alors pour vous dire tout d'abord
que tous les résultats ne sont pas
encore connues puisque tous les
bulletins n'ont pas encore été
dépouillés en revanche c'est quasiment
sûr dans la 2e circonscription à celle
de l'avallonnais et bien c'est jean yves
caullet le député sortant qui arriverait
en tête devant andré villiers le
président du conseil départemental qui
pour l'instant ne serait pas qualifié
pour le second tour
merci sébastien pour ces précisions je
vous propose de retrouver en duplex
gabriel amard de la france insoumise qui
est avec nous de lons le saunier bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous on donne des
résultats autour de 12% pour la france a
soumis ce soit vous êtes bien loin du
score de jean luc mélenchon à la
présidentielle
[Musique]
pour une force qui s'est créée il ya un
an et demi qui n'est pas un parti
politique mais un mouvement un réseau de
citoyens
c'est une belle avance et puis ici dans
le jura nous avons la satisfaction la
première circonscription d'être vraiment
à 14 % étant en tête du camp des
humanistes et des écologistes
et puis surtout la grande satisfaction
d'avoir battu le front national qui est
derrière nous c'était pour nous aussi un
objectif faire reculer l'extrême droite
dans cette élection
oui gabriel amard on a entendu tout à
l'heure christophe sirugue donc l'ancien
ministre de françois hollande qui est
battu et qui dit que la france insoumise
fait qu'il n'y a pas de représentants de
gauche au deuxième tour
comment vous réagissez à ces propos
écoutez depuis le début nous avons
annoncé par la campagne présidentielle
qu'il y aura une seule élection
présidentielle et législatives
nous avons un programme cohérent nous
sommes en dehors des partis politiques
traditionnels
nous proposons aux peuples de se fédérer
pour en finir avec l'oligarchie
les gens qui prennent la politique pour
un jeu où des affaires où les logiques
de captation du pouvoir pour eux mêmes
on le voit en ce moment même parmi le
gouvernement donc non nous sommes
cohérents et personne n'a été pris entre
est la france insoumise ne participe pas
aux combines avec les partis politiques
traditionnels
merci gabriel amard de cette première
réaction en direct de lons le saunier on
va tout de suite se rendre à la
préfecture de région à dijon où nous
attend emmanuel pinsonneault avec des
résultats du côté de la côte d'or
emmanuel oui dans la 4e circonscription
tout d'abord violaine de course au pour
la république en marche seraient élus
dès le premier tour avec 13 points 4 8 %
des inscrits 25% des suffrages exprimés
les autres candidats ne pouvant pas se
maintenir pour ce second tour
et puis dans la 5e circonscription
même schéma pour le candidat de la
république en marche dit-il parisse qui
obtient 37% des suffrages exprimés
devant le divers droite hubert poullot
24% et la candide le candidat du front
national rené lloret 17% des suffrages
exprimés
merci pour ces premières informations
emmanuel pinsonneault depuis la
préfecture de région il y en a là une
précision vraie petite rectification
faite y aura bien deux candidats au
deuxième tour dans ces deux
circonscriptions il y avait sur pas dès
le deuxième tour
le ce plafond n'est pas le niveau n'est
pas atteint et tu crois la participation
étant faible la chose n'est pas possible
on fait quand même remarquer qu' on est
là si ça se confirme dans deux
circonscriptions qu'ils étaient des
circonscriptions de droite de côte-d'or
la quatrième on va leur dire c'était la
cirrhose et plan de françois sauvadet
qui est à droite depuis que ces
circonscriptions ont été découpés et
puis la 5e un petit mot quand même
c'était celle d'alain suguenot maire de
beaune mais ç'a aussi été celle de
françois patriat très proches
conseillers d'emmanuel macron par le jeu
des alternances politiques
on va donner la parole à catherine
vandriesse pour les républicains puisque
selon les estimations au niveau national
les républicains arrive en deuxième
position en terme de voix alors
évidemment ça ne dit pas tout de la
projection en sièges qu'on saura en fin
de soirée mais catherine vandriesse une
réaction la première réaction c'est que
malgré tout on consolide une base
électorale donc évidemment on peut pas
satisfaire d'un résultat relativement
médiocre mais ça veut dire que la base
électorale des républicains malgré aussi
des élections présidentielles est
relativement maintenu et se comporte
plutôt bien moi la vraie question ce
soir c'est l'absence de débat je trouve
sur les vrais problèmes à la fois
sociétaux et politiques en france et
l'absence de clarté dans marche je vais
vous donner deux sujets très très
important à mes yeux le problème le
premier sujet c'est le sujet de la
sécurité et du maintien de l'état
d'urgence
notre parti a vu des positions
extrêmement clair sur les positions par
exemple sur la majorité pénale ramené à
16 ans et des positions qui seront
présentés par nos parlementaires
moi je voudrais aujourd'hui avoir des
positions d'un marche sur ce sujet est
le deuxième sujet important qui est la
défense du bord d'achat déjà notre
groupe parlementaire ad
indiqué qu'il aurait une proposition de
loi sur la défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires c'est un vrai niveau et
un vrai outil de maintien du pouvoir
d'achat pour tous les salariés
ce n'est pas des propositions retenues
par en marche des cg on en a longuement
parlé mais ça ait réellement un impact
fiscal oui mais c'est des vrais qui sont
formés mais sur le résultat de cette
élection quand on lance une projection à
21,5 pour cent pour l'instant pour les
républicains
mais ça englobe quand même un certain
nombre de gens qui ont voté pour les
républicains pour un certain nombre de
candidats qui se sont dit appartenir à
la majorité des manuels macron cirque à
l'intérieur de ces 21 pour ça on est
d'accord qu'il ya des gens qui sont dans
l'opposition
des gens qui sont dans une opposition
constructive des gens qui sont dans une
majorité des gens qui sont majorité
relative oui vous savez vous savez très
bien que la féline il ya un premier
ministre de droite
vous savez très bien que ça des
républicains la fuite entre guillemets
de candidats sur potentiellement affiché
en marge est très très faible minimes 1
donc quelles que soient les résultats de
ce soir on restera le deuxième groupe
politique en tout cas l'assemblée
nationale et je reviens sur ces
discussions et ses positions de fo parce
que nous avons déjà décidé d'ailleurs
les ténors nationaux ont déjà indiqué
qu'il y aurait des positions très
claires et des propositions de textes
très clair rapidement sur des vrais
sujets de société qui à mon avis dans
cette danse est quant à elle à la fois
présidentielle est relative n'ont pas
été posées donc il faut aussi que en
marche soit beaucoup plus clair sur en
dehors des 120 propositions et un peu
quelquefois des effets de manche sur
lequel le président la république a très
bien géré et d'ailleurs ce mois de
campagne non existence
on va rejoindre notre studio de besançon
où nous attend sophie montel eurodéputés
fn conseillère régionale évidemment
sophie montel ce soir est ce que vous
êtes déçu de ses résultats au niveau
national pour le front national qui ne
transforme pas l'essai de l'élection
présidentielle oui évidemment avec une
moyenne nationale qui est donnée de
l'ordre de 13 14% évidemment j'aurais
préféré que nous soyons bien au delà de
cette moyenne ce soir
effectivement je note que l'électorat de
monsieur macron premier tour s'est
mobilisée et au deuxième tour s'est
mobilisée pour les élections
législatives pour le premier tour des
législatives vous savez ce que monsieur
masseron il n'y a pas que monsieur
macron qui est fort vous aussi vous êtes
faible parce que 14%
c'est bien loin quand même du score de
marine le pen à l'élection
présidentielle c'est indéniable il ya un
écart entre votre leader national et
vous candidat sur le terrain dont
certains d'ailleurs on n'a même pas vu
sur pendant la campagne
est ce que je peux vous répondre les
élections prévues savait que la loi
était modifiée pour que les élections
législatives soient situées juste à
quelques mois à quelques semaines de
l'élection présidentielle
et cette volonté du législateur et du
politique elle est évidemment avec une
arrière-pensée c'est que quand vous
gagnez l'élection présidentielle vous
avez toutes les chances d'avoir une
majorité écrasante
quelques semaines plus tard lors des
élections législatives c'est ce qui est
en train de se passer aujourd'hui c'est
ce qui se confirmera très certainement
lors du deuxième tour de l'élection
législative le 18 juin malgré tout effet
malgré tout entre les 22 je sens de
marine le pen au premier tour et des 14%
aujourd'hui vous voyez bien que mis à
part quelques leaders comme vous
d'ailleurs qui arrivait à faire votre
place sur le terrain politique en
général vos candidats n'arrivent pas à
percer
oui mais il ya certainement aussi c'est
le but d'ailleurs c'est ce qui va se
passer après ces élections législatives
marine l'a annoncé lors du soir du
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle il va falloir qu'on se
pose des questions
voir où nous avons pêché voir comment
vraiment constitué une machine de guerre
moi je c'est vrai que je suis je suis
déçu ce soir je suis déçu je considère
qu'un certain nombre de nos électeurs
des électeurs qui ont voté à l'élection
présidentielle ne se sont pas déplacés
je le regrette je regrette qu'un certain
nombre de nos compatriotes aient préféré
passer l'après-midi devant un bon
barbecue sous le soleil plutôt que
d'aller prendre cinq minutes de leur
temps pour aller glisser le bulletin de
vote du front national dans l'urne mais
bon je ne fais je ne peut que le
constater maintenant il va falloir que
effectivement nous allions de l'avant et
que
nous nous refondons notre mouvement et
que nous allions parce qu'il y aille il
y a aujourd'hui un véritable il ya plus
de droite ya plus de gauche on le voit
bien c'est vraiment le camp des
mondialistes contre le camp des
patriotes donc il va falloir qu'on
s'organise pour être beaucoup plus
efficace pour aller de l'avant
mais je ne doute pas que nous aurons des
députés à l'assemblée nationale la
semaine prochaine mais arrêter on verra
merci madame vous étiez en direct de
notre studio de besançon je vous propose
de retrouver toujours en direct
catherine gabrel candidate la république
en marche dans la 4e circonscription de
saône-et-loire bonsoir même gabrel vous
arrivé en tête ce soit ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire juste au niveau des
chiffres qui sont les vôtres et bien je
suis en tête devant cécile enter
meilleur je pense qu'ils en 2d on
devrait être toutes les deux qualifiées
pour le second tour et après je pense
que c'est serré entre les républicains
et maxime thiébaut le front national
catherine cabrel est ce que c'est une
surprise pour vous on va dire que vous
étiez un peu la candidate surprise s'est
pas forcé vous je vais y arriver c'est
pas forcément vous qu'on attendait comme
candidate dans marges vous même
peut-être aussi qu'est ce qui s'est
passé dans cette campagne vous êtes
poussé par le vent dans marque joue
c'est votre implantation locale
je pense qu'il ya déjà beaucoup mon
implantation locale sur le tournoi
j'ai fait un très bon score sur le
tournoi
je suis connue et reconnue donc ça c'est
déjà important et puis je pense qu on
est parti c'est vrai en retard parce que
j'étais investi dans la deuxième vague
mais avec ma suppléante on sait surtout
beaucoup investi on a aussi des
démarcheurs qu'elle ait des maires de
communes voisines qui nous ont bien
soutenu et c'est c'était vraiment une
expérience formidable pour moi merci
d'avoir été en direct avec nous donc un
mot un bon jean christophe hardaway ce
joujou coup puisque maxime divo et sur
notre plateau vous étiez le candidat
pour le front national dans cette dans
cette circonscription
votre réaction d'abord on va s'ouvrir
circonscription front national avec
au score à l'élection présidentielle ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que les
électeurs du front national de la
présidentielle ils sont pas allés voter
ça les intéresse plus ou alors c'est le
débat de marine le pen un peu raté cas
pas fonctionné c'est peut-être le
mouvement créé par monsieur philippe
haut c'est quoi non ce qui s'est passé
cette l'opposition s'est pas mobilisée
et vous avez eu aussi une faible
mobilisation des des électeurs dans
marche ce qui s'est passé dans cette
élection législative c'est que les gens
ne sont pas allés voter
et moi je suis assez triste parce que
notre démocratie est malade d'une
abstention très forte et il ya eu le
fait majoritaire c'est à dire que
jacques chirac avait permis à ce que
l'assemblée nationale suivent l'élection
du président de la république et donc il
est tout naturel qu'il ya un peu plus de
deux voix pour les candidats dans marche
moi ce qui me steam dérange c'est ya pu
vraiment d'opposition aujourd'hui dans
ce pays les républicains sont avec en
marché en marche et l'opposition
française ne s'est pas mobilisée et ça
c'est dommage moi je pense et je le
savais je le sentais sur le terrain les
gens me disaient façon c'est plié
on n'est pas d'accord avec le président
de la république mais c'est plié et il
ya eu un défaut de mobilisation les 2
front national est en crise après cette
présidentielle est parce que voilà on va
le dire il se passe des choses en ce
moment en interne au front national il
ya un nouveau mouvement qui se créent à
l'intérieur vous en faites partie vous
venez de debout la france vous en faites
partie
il a explosé le front national non il a
pâti close et ce qui se passe c'est
qu'on est en train de refonder le front
national on est en train de refonder
l'opposition à monsieur macron une
opposition patriotes face aux
mondialistes il s'appelle monsieur macro
et ce qui est dommage ce soir et à la
raison sophie c'est que on aurait dû
avoir une mobilisation de notre
électorat qui aurait dû espérer créer
une vraie opposition à maquereau et ça
n'a pas été le cas
donc j'ai une petite déception je sais
pas mon score hexagonal se demander si
je suis ici je sais mon record catherine
vandriesse pour les pour les
républicains voulaient s'exprimer
suite à ce que vient de dire maxime
thibeault et puis ensuite on ira voir du
côté d'internet ce qui se passe oui
parce que l'intervention de monsieur
thibault lé ressemble beaucoup à celle
qu'on retrouve au conseil régional mais
on peut pas nier
le résultat dans marches ce soir
évidemment et je pense que personne ne
fait ce soir on a une résistance réelle
des républicains qu'il ne s'effondre pas
dans les résultats comme le front
national le manifeste aujourd'hui je
voulais juste terminé mais ce qui veut
dire aussi qu'il ya maintenant parce que
on va attendre le deuxième tour de
dimanche mais il ya un vrai débat de
société sur des vraies positions en
termes de fiscalité de sécurité et de
pouvoir d'achat qui va falloir que entre
autres en marche éclaircies sous ses
positions et on a une position très
claire sur ce que générique avant
s'exprimer encore on va rejoindre dans
un instant et bien damien meslot
le député sortant et maire de belfort
mais d'abord on va rejoindre
elle a besoin pour un tour sur le web
soyez cette république en marche crise
serait loin devant regarder ce message
de marien lovichi qui est conseiller
municipal modem et qui écrit vous le
voyez côte-d'or strike
voilà merci est là on va tout de suite
se rendre à belfort où on va retrouver
damien meslot député sortant et maire de
la ville les républicains damien meslot
vous n'étiez plus candidat à cette
élection par contre vous soutenir un
poulain et puis en face de vous il y
avait un centriste qui est un ennemi de
longue date si je puis dire
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez ce soir
à sept heures des premiers résultats
oui tout à fait actuellement les
résultats définitifs de la
circonscription donne la république en
marche en tête avec 31 devant nous
autour de 24 % d'eau qu'on s'achemine
vers un duel entre la république en
marche et yanbu car le candidat des
républicains qui fait un très bon score
pour son son premier premier parcours
électoral et par rapport aux sondages
nationaux
nous sommes deux points au-dessus de la
moyenne nationale de nos candidats tous
qu'il va y avoir un deuxième tour ouvert
en duel entre la réprimer mariama
signate bout car damien meslot vous
contenter d'un 24% sur votre
circonscription sur votre ville belfort
est-ce que c'est pas quand même un petit
peu faire j'allais dire comment c'est
l'expression mauvaise fortune bon coeur
parce que franchement c'est pas bon quoi
catherine il ya une vague dans marches
ce soir donc j'aurais préféré évidemment
que les résultats soient inversés je ne
vous le cache pas le résultat n'est pas
exceptionnel mais par rapport à ce qui
se passe nous résistons et nous allons
préparer le deuxième tour parce que vous
savez c'est comme dans les matchs de
foot
si vous suivez ce show des fois dans les
dernières minutes on prend des buts qui
inversent le résultat donc nous nous
allons nous battre bâton parce qu'il ya
des réserves de moi il ya beaucoup
d'abstentionnistes et on va regarder les
reports qui sont possibles de notre côté
nous pensons que la république en marche
a fait le plein au premier tour et nous
allons nous battre mais sur le deuxième
tour mais vous l'avez noté
nous sommes deuxièmes il est anglais
non mais c'était pour merci du tout
damien meslot en direct de belfort
voulait nous donner des résultats à lyon
on fait bien notre passé nous l'avait
évoqué tout à l'heure à la préfecture de
la préfecture de côte-d'or 4e
circonscription de côte-d'or montbard
châtillon et yolaine de courson la
candidate dans marche est en tête devant
lui des hits charles barrière deux
choses
deux remarques sur cette circonscription
à la présidentielle sur cette
circonscription
le frud c'est marine le pen qui était en
tête au premier tour de la
présidentielle avec 26 5 % sur sept sur
sept circonscriptions sylvie beaulieu
n'est qu'en quatrième position et puis
une autre remarque y avait deux
candidats de droite charles barrière qui
avait l'investiture ideye l'air et
hubert brigand le maire de châtillon il
n'y a que 33 voix d'écart entre les deux
candidats d'après ces résultats
ce qui veut dire qu'on n'était pas au
bout de nos peines sur d'éventuelles
contestations
un mot là-dessus pour ne rien vous
cacher on avait parlé avec françois
patriat il ya quelques jours et qui
prenait l'exemple de la côte d'or qu'ils
disaient
en marche gagnera probablement trois
circonscriptions si on en gagne cinq si
on les gagne tout ça veut dire que rune
vague nationale est forte
c'est ça qui est en train de se passer
c'est pas une vague c'est beaucoup plus
qu'une vague
6une questions j'y réponds oui oui oui
clairement la 5e circonscription est
maintenant mâcon est arrivé en troisième
position au premier tour et une
circonscription vous l'avez dit françois
va trier en a été l'élu mais il ya déjà
un certain temps elle était quand même
très bien tenues par la droite candidat
droit qui ont fait une campagne
particulière je dirais un peu recto
verso entre deux candidats pour faire
simple et moi je considère qu' il ya une
vraie poussée si vous permettez quand
même un mot pour répondre à madame je
coule
héritant d je trouve quand même un peu
étrange ce soir de contester à la
république en marche une part de la
clarté de son programme
rappelons-nous et c'est quand même
récent que le la présidentielle était
axée sur un poème tout à fait par tuer
main je qualifie de casse sociale team
en clair et qu' il est quand même
extrêmement compliqué pour un électeur
même qu'ils s'y intéressent de retrouver
les éléments d'évolution de ce bois mais
les points de fixation de ce programme
j'aurais tendance à dire que c'est
pareil pour au front national puisque
mon voisin de gauche le comté sera sans
doute mais l'ensemble du programme du
front national était basée sur la sortie
de l'europe et de l'euro
aujourd'hui vous répondrais cette sortie
n'a pas eu lieu
c'était quand même 70 % du programme qui
était basé sur financement de ce
programme qui a été basée sur ce terrain
là n'ayant pas eu lieu
on peut légitimement se demander où un
tour de passe-passe la somme sortie
actuelle c'est celle de filippo prévu
pour les républicains l'ensemble du
programme des républiques à ma
connaissance et 25 milliard d'euros
de delta où seront les points de tva ou
aurait été plus exactement et
heureusement nous allons peut-être
parler au passé sir deuxième tour
confirme ce mouvement ce que je souhaite
ou aurait été la situation financière
exacte de la france dans ces conditions
si départ il va écouter si vous voulez
bien un autre soutien d' emmanuel macron
c'est le président socialiste du conseil
départemental de haute saône yves
krattinger bons soient en direct de
vesoul il tranché ce soir c'est la
débâcle du parti socialiste est ce que
vous avez l'impression d'y avoir
participé
en soutenant emmanuel mac j'entends pas
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
d'avoir participé à la débâcle du parti
socialiste en soutenant emmanuel macron
côté mots j'ai décidé de soutenir
emmanuel macron les deux candidats que
j'ai accompagné dans cette élection sont
très nettement en tête tous les deux
qualifiés pour le deuxième tour
il n'ya pas d'autre chose a constaté à
ce stade tout ce que vous êtes en train
de dire yves krattinger c'est que
barbara beso ballots sur la première
circonscription et christophe lejeune
sur la 2ème sont en tête mais est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire contre qui
justement ils seront au deuxième tour
dimanche prochain
si vous avez plus de résultats que nous
les côtés sur la 2e circonscription je
pense qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'inconnues ce sera certainement contre
le candidat du front national sur la
première c'est actuellement contre le
candidat du front national mais tant que
tous les résultats ne seront pas connus
c'est quand même rester une
interrogation c'est quand même
extrêmement significatif que dans votre
département donc on vous tenez le
département donc depuis très longtemps
il y ait des candidats en marche contre
des candidats front national sa veux
dire que la droite classique a
complètement disparu du paysage
dans la 2 n'est pas très en forme depuis
très longtemps
donc ce n'est pas vraiment une surprise
dans la première circonscription elle
était divisée et je pense qu'elles
doivent le regretter ce soir elle aurait
peut-être pu être qualifié pour le
deuxième tour elle peut encore l'être
mais ça sera difficile
et donc c'est à elle qu'il faut poser la
question et vous vous êtes content de
toute façon pour ces résultats pour
votre département
écoutez moi j'ai fait un choix il a été
au début difficile à comprendre par mes
partenaires et ensuite la plupart
d'entre eux sont venus sur la même
position que moi
ce soir nous sommes très contents de ce
résultat de premier tour il y a eu
mobilisation de la plupart de nos amis
en faveur des candidats en marche et
tout reste à faire quand même pour le
deuxième tour il va continuer à
rassembler les électeurs il faut
continuer à merci merci merci je vais
avoir entre nous depuis le zoom lilian
melet ont fait un point sur les
résultats qui nous parviennent d'autres
résultats qu'on vous l'a dit tout à
l'heure la quatrième de côte-d'or la
candidate dans marche en première
position devant lui dlr charles barrière
5e circonscription de côte-d'or la vôtre
didier parisse vous êtes en tête avec
37,15 devant le candidat de droite
hubert poullot et puis troisième
circonscription de l'yonne ce résultat
nous ne l'avions pas encore et c'est la
candidate en marche michel cros la
troisième de l'yonne c'est le nord de
l'yonne
là où le front national a réussi ses
plus gros score à la présidentielle en
bourgogne
c'est la candidate en marche michel
crouzet qui arrive en tête avec 28,6
devant julien odoul conseiller régional
front national en deuxième position la
candidate les républicains clarisse
quentin est éliminé ainsi que le
candidat du parti socialiste dominique
bourreau qui n'a que 5 oui or deux
résultats concernant le département du
doubs temps la 5e circonscription c'est
celle de pontarlier morteau
annie john var la députée des
républicains arrive en tête avec un peu
plus de 38% des voix mais est qualifié
également sylvie le hir qui est une
conseillère départementale qui a été élu
en 2015 avec l'étiquette ump et qui
totalise plus de 33% des suffrages
donc annie genevard sylvie le ive dans
la 5ème du doubs et puis celle que nous
attendions avec beaucoup d'impatience
est la quatrième du doubs on disait que
frédéric barbier le député socialiste
qui avait aussi l'éthique est en marche
et bien dans cette circonscription
il totalise plus de 37% des suffrages
il sera opposé dimanche prochain à
sophie montel du front national mais qui
ne totalise que 24% des voix donc duel
barbier montel avec montel qui est très
très mal placée par rapport au score
qu'elle avait réalisé en janvier 2015
j'ai envie de poser une question à
michel neugnot parce que yves krattinger
ne m'a pas répondu il ya un instant mais
est-ce que
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
les socialistes comme yves krattinger
qui ont soutenu la république en marche
ont participé à la débâcle de vos
résultats ce soir débâcle du ps ce soir
je pense que ce qu'a dit dufay la
présidente
je pense que le choix tactiques
d'emmanuel mâcon dès le début va aller à
son aboutissement se dire une large
victoire d'un marche parce qu'en disant
et de droite et de gauche on sait très
bien qu'au deuxième tour ce sera un
affrontement droite contre en marche et
récupérant voix de la gauche et
inversement
et quand ce sera contre le fn ils
recueilleront tout donc la mécanique à
fonctionner il faut le reconnaître des
joies dire bravo l'artiste
mais où ces aidants dans toutes les
périodes tout le monde aura des
difficultés
la difficulté est la première des
figures ça sera comme nous parti
socialiste ceux qui ont perdu et on peut
dire que vu l'étendue des scores des
rythmes des en marche
tous les autres ont perdu mais il y aura
aussi si vous permettez les difficultés
après une large victoire
et effectivement le problème qui va se
poser c'est si on va boire des réformes
peuvent être opposées et de droite et de
gauche les bonnes idées et de droite et
des rouges
je pense que la lui la sphère va être
quelque peu complexe pour tout le monde
pour tout le monde
où donc moi je reste de monter cette
situation à l'apprécier en sachant très
bien que comme l'a dit guillet il ya une
volonté très forte encore plus amplifiée
qui explique peut être aussi une une
partie de désintérêt pour le scrutin
la sphère étant dans l'esprit beaucoup
plié c'est pas la peine d'y aller
merci michel le nom on va on va
rejoindre à à belfort denise où mme
keller le sel
michel où mme keller le président hu 10
du territoire de belfort michel keller
bonsoir un amour parce que évidemment
vous êtes udi donc on pense que la
république en marche a pris pas mal de
place aux centristes
ce soir j'aurais pu espérer de meilleurs
résultats
oui je alors effectivement je pense
qu'on attendait tous de meilleurs
résultats que ça ça c'est incontestable
est-ce que c'est aux centristes ou pas
il ya quand même 50 % de participation
seulement
donc je crois que voilà le résultat
évidemment très intéressant pour en
marche
on espère nous que la semaine prochaine
ça sera quand même une haute élections
voilà en tout cas sur scène certaines
circonscriptions
je sais pas s'il prend lui dit je sais
pas si prompts et l'air je pense qu'il
prend un petit peu à tout le monde
il prend aussi beaucoup au ps -cinq ans-
même reconnaissez-le donc voilà on va
voir on va voir un petit peu ce qui se
passe il reste une semaine
michel rouquet l'air comme on n'a pas
les résultats de votre circonscription
est ce que vous êtes qualifiés pour le
deuxième tour et contre qui est ce que
c'est bruno kern de la république en
marche
oui alors vous êtes devant ou pas c'est
pas un c'est pas non non il est devant
il est devant 1,29 et je suis à 24
quelque chose comme ça va donc céder
tout de même 24 actions pour un député
sortant c'est alors que vous êtes je lui
déjà pour déjà leur mandat vous êtes
bien influence est maire d'une commune
importante c'est quand même pas
énormément de scor énormément de voix
non mais c'est très difficile moi je
vous le cache pas c'est une déception je
vous cache pas non plus je crois qu'il
ya un moment quand on se présente à une
élection c'est pour faire des voix et
convaincre les électeurs
si les électeurs ne sont pas content de
mon travail il me renverrons chez moi la
semaine prochaine j'ai pas de souci avec
ça mais effectivement c'est une
déception
après je crois que le sujet c'est voilà
moi j'avais pas monsieur macron contre
manger monsieur kern donc les électeurs
il faut qu'ils comprennent qu'ils vont
choisir un député et il faudra savoir
quel député ils veulent c'est ce qu'on
va leur dire semaine prochaine s'ils
veulent monsieur kern et choisiront
monsieur qu'est remercie beaucoup à
leurs besoins
le combat continuera même après dimanche
prochain merci avec nous en direct ce
soit pour cette soirée législatives
exceptionnelle sur france 3 on va tout
de suite du côté d'auxerre parce que
sébastien kérouas un résultat à nous
donner je crois dans la 2e
circonscription de l'yonne sébastien
tout à fait c'est cela la 2e
circonscription à celle de l'avallonnais
et bien c'est jean yves caullet 1 qui
donc le candidat de la république en
marchant qui arrive en tête avec 30% des
suffrages exprimés
largement devant andré villiers un de
lui dit andré valiquette à 22%
il y aura donc bien un second tour la
république en marche
udi au second tour voilà donc dans la
deuxième star cossia conception de
l'yonne pardon merci sébastien en direct
d'auxerre catherine est mairie pour des
résultats en franche comté
oui tout d'abord dans le jura la 2e
circonscription c'est celle de saint
claude marie christine dalloz députée
sortante est en ballottage elle a
totalisé un peu plus de 29% des voix et
la taignonnes la candidate de la
république en marche à une progr aux
gens qui totalisent plus de 27% à 2 voix
donc il va falloir commencer à voir
comment se comporte par exemple les
électeurs de la france insoumise ceux de
julie lançons qui a totalisé plus de 12%
des suffrages
et puis dans le doubs dans la troisième
circonscription celle de montbéliard
ouest ballottage favorable pour denis
sommaire et que ce socialiste candidat
de la france en marche
il totalise presque 34 % des voix devant
le candidat des républicains frédéric
quartier maire de sens et avec un peu
plus de 25% des voix on retrouve ces
deux hommes au deuxième tour dimanche
prochain
lilian melet un petit mot pour compléter
ce que disent et sébastien qui roule sur
la 2e circonscription de l'aisne de
l'yonne va rappeler que jean yves
caullet c'est un des premiers
parlementaires socialistes à avoir
rejoint emmanuel macron et pour
illustrer la perte des voix du front
national dans cette circonscription on
l'avait remarqué marine le pen s'était
29% au premier tour de la présidentielle
et de vie jacques et la candidate elle a
perdu il ya dix points de pertes 19%
pour ce premier tour des législatives
même répondent c'est ya eu 50 %
d'abstention et je suis désolé mais au
deuxième tour les candidats front
national n'ont pas perdu si l'opposition
se mobilise si les électeurs ont compris
qu'il faut pas laisser une majorité les
pleins pouvoirs à monsieur macro nous
pouvons avoir des quand il sent pas la
rose électeurs manifestement ils sont
bien se sont pas déplacés au premier
tour on n'a pas su réaliser
il ya eu un défaut de mobilisation
explique comment l'expliquons
l'expliquent par une campagne courte on
l'expliquent par le fait qu'il ya eu un
fait majoritaire pour monsieur macron
par le fait qu'on doit aussi se réformer
et on va les ce que vous avez au jeu
faut vraiment de cette campagne il par
exemple avait des doutes après le débat
de l'élection présidentielle donc on a
beaucoup parlé sur le comportement de
marine le pen
mais marine le pen de toute façon sur
tf1 a fait son mea culpa sur le débat
donc les gens l'ont compris
moi ce que j'ai entendu sur le terrain
c'est la nécessité de construire une
vraie opposition de réformer le front
national de rassembler large et c'est ce
qu'on va faire
florian philippot il va pas quitter le
front national il va conforter le front
national vous venez de lire avec florian
philippot donc pas avec marine le pen
marine le pen aussi la réponse blanche
je réponds tout à l'heure où fait ils
disaient qu'ils allaient sortir du front
national c'est pas du tout la question
logique non l'objectif c'est de
construire une vraie force d'opposition
de savoir regarder ses erreurs ce que ne
font pas les républicains qui vont aller
tout de suite couché avec monsieur
macron notre objectif c'est de parvenir
à constituer une vraie opposition face
aux mondialistes qui s'appelle monsieur
macron et qui va soumettre notre pays a
des intérêts à l'étrange voyage
utilisera les mêmes mots vrai ce que
vous aller fricoter avec monsieur macron
c'est pas maintenant
en tout cas on a pas d'hésitation pour
savoir si je reste ou pas dans l'euro
vous voyez par exemple sur des points
très précis il ya des changements
y a pas de changement de position en
l'espace d'un mois de campagne
électorale des positions claires en tout
cas sur ce sujet là et sur les freak
hautement je vous ai donné la réponse
tout à l'heure il ya pas eu beaucoup de
fric hautement autres alliés une
personne physique premier ministre
aujourd'hui qui est un choix des
personnels et décision qui a été prise
et la purge que vont n'aurait pu
imaginer des républicains
mais au lieu de vous a fait vous savez
par exemple deux députés des
républicains très très bien installés
dans leur territoire
marie christine dalloz dans le jura et
annie jeunes verts vaart dans le haut
doubs marie christine dalloz père 4000
voix elle passe de 12000 à 8000 si l'on
compare le premier tour de 2012 est le
premier tour ce soit et puis pour annie
genevard c'est pareil elle parle elle
part de plus de 19 mille voix elle en a
quinze mille donc c'est pas le même
candidat
résultat on sera d'une autre
circonscription est ce que je les ai pas
tourné trois journées ainsi que dans la
circonscription de la ville de hull où
les choses se passent très bien que le
candidat sortant donc vous voyez que
c'est aussi très lié aux candidats à
leur implantation locale et le deuxième
tour corrigera d'ailleurs je le pense
les estimations qu'on peut avoir la
actuellement mais pour revenir sur sur
la question vous avez posé c'est trop
facile
c'est trop facile parce que ce que je
regarde monsieur pâris moi j'attends
avec impatience la rentrée parlementaire
et les positions des uns et des autres y
compris dans marche quand monsieur tout
à l'heure vous m'avez fait un reproche
sur le budget des républicains mais vous
trouvez normal quand même période d'état
d'urgence
votre président de la république votre
candidat 4 casey 2,6 milliards d'euros
les dotations du budget de l'état se
sont plaints que les parlementaires
aient des positions concrètes et les
explique cumul des mandats s'arrêtant
sur leur circonscription des personnages
enfin la marolle michel crouzet
candidate la république en marche dans
la troisième circonscription de l'yonne
qui est en direct avec nous michel
crouzet un mot peut-être sur vos
résultats
bonsoir bonsoir à tous et à toutes
écoutez effectivement on peut on peut se
réjouir d'une d'une première place dans
la 3e circonscription la circonscription
je représente cependant ce qu'on peut
déplorer c'est un taux de participation
qui soit aussi faible
puisqu'on est en dessous des 50% et ça
c'est on note un réel des
investissements des électeurs vis-à-vis
de la vie politique et c'est bien
dommage alors peut-être que le beau
temps favorable n'a pas emmené les gens
dans les urnes mais on peut le déplorer
cependant de quelques rounds je réalise
michel crouzet ces lignes en mêlée sur
le plateau dijon front national sera au
deuxième qui s'avoue avec julien odoul
vous en appelez à tout le monde à
clarisse quentin la candidate qui
étaient investis vous en appelez au
candidat du parti socialiste face au
front national ou pas ce soir alors bien
sûr bien sûr on peut dire que en fait
les candidats et les républicains ont
fait une campagne honorable et on les en
remercie bien évidemment et l'objectif
pour nous est effectivement c'est de
combattre le front national les idées
qu'ils représentent un pas les électeurs
qui ont pu voter pour eux mais les idées
qu'ils représentent
je note que j'ai fini le la république
en marche a fini en tête dans pas mal de
communes qui votait jusque là beaucoup
front national donc on peut noter une
régression du front national sachant
qu'ils n'atteignent pas les douze
ennemis des veaux des inscrits sur sur
le nombre de votants
donc ça c'est quand même une très belle
une très belle nouvelle merci d'avoir
été en direct avec nous ce soir pour
cette première réaction merci également
à nos invités qui étaient en plateau
avec nous voilà pour ce qu'on pouvait
dire à 7 heures en régions et bien sûr
les résultats et les réactions c'est en
temps réel sur notre site internet
bfc point france 3 point fr on se
retrouve au plus près de chez vous à
21h15 et la soirée continue bien sûr
[Musique]